The international banking system is an enigma.
There are more than 30,000 different banks worldwide and the hold unbelievable
amounts of assets.
The top 10 banks alone account for roughly 25 trillion us daughters today.
Banking can seem very complex,
but originally the idea was to make life simpler.
11th Century,
Italy was the center of European trading merchants from all over the continent,
Matt,
to trade their goods,
but there was one problem,
too many currencies in circulation in Piza.
Merchants had to deal with seven different types of coins and had to exchange
their money constantly.
This exchange business,
which commonly to place outdoors on benches is where we get the word bank from,
from the word bankable battalion for badge.
The dangers of traveling,
counterfeit money and the difficulty of getting alone got people thinking it was
time for a new business model.
Pawnbrokers started to give credit to businessmen while Genovese merchants
developed cashless payments.
Networks of banks spread all over Europe handing out credit even to the church.
Oh,
European kings.
What about today?
In a nutshell,
banks are in the risk management business.
This is a simplified version of the way it works.
People keep their money in banks and receive a small amount of interest.
The bank takes this money and lends it out at much higher interest rates.
It's a calculated risk because some of the vendors,
it will default on their credit.
This process is essential for our economic system because it provides resources
for people to buy things like houses or for industry to expand their businesses
and grow.
So banks take funds that are unused by savers and turned them into funds society
can use to do stuff.
Other sources of income for banks include accepting,
saving deposits,
the credit card business and buying and selling currencies,
custodian business and cash management services.
The main problem with banks nowadays is that a lot of them have abandoned their
traditional role as providers of longterm financial products in favor of short
term gains that carry much higher risks during the financial boom.
Most major banks adopted financial constraints that were badly comprehensible
and did their own trading in a bit to make fast money and earn their executives
and traders millions in bonuses.
This was nothing short of gambling and damaged whole economies and societies
linked back in 2008 when banks life Lehman Brothers gave credit to basically
anyone who wanted to buy a house and thereby put the bank in an extremely
dangerous risk position.
This led to the collapse of the housing market in the U S and parts of Europe
causing stock prices to plummet,
which eventually led to a global bank and crisis and one of the largest
financial crises in history.
Hundreds of billions of just evaporated.
Millions of people lost their jobs and lots of money.
Most of the world's major banks had to pay billions in fines and bankers became
some of the least trusted professionals.
The U s government and the European Union had to put together a huge bailout
packages to purchase bad assets and stop the banks from going bankrupt.
New regulations were put into force to govern the banking business.
Compulsory Bank emergency funds when forced to absorb shocks in the event of
another financial crisis,
but other pieces of tough new legislation,
we're successfully blocked by the banking lobby today.
Other models of providing financing are gaining ground fast,
like new investment banks that charge a yearly fee and do not get commissions on
sales,
thus providing the motivation to act in the best interests of their clients or
credit unions.
Corporative initiatives that were established in the 19th century to circumvent
credit sharks.
In a nutshell,
they provide the same financial services as banks put focus on shared value
rather than profit maximization.
The self proclaimed goal is to help members create opportunities length starting
small businesses,
expanding farms or building family homes while investing back into communities.
They are controlled by their members who also elect the board of directors.
Democratically.
Worldwide Credit Union systems vary significantly ranging from a handful of
members to organization's worth several billion US dollars and hundreds of
thousands of members.
The focus on benefits for their members impacts the risk credit unions are
willing to take,
which explains why credit unions,
although also hurting,
survived the last financial crisis way better than traditional banks.
Not to forget the explosion of crowdfunding in recent years.
Aside from making awesome video games,
possible platforms of rose that enabled people to get loans from large groups of
small investors circumventing the bank as a middleman,
but it also works for industry.
Lots of new technology companies started out on Kickstarter or Indiegogo.
The funding individual gets the satisfaction of being part of a bigger thing and
can invest in ideas.
They believe it while spreading the risk so widely that if the project fails,
the damage is limited.
And last but not least,
microcredit lots of very small loans,
mostly handed out in developing countries that help people escape poverty.
People who were previously unable to get access to the money they needed to
start a business because they weren't deemed worth the taimen.
Nowadays,
the granting of micro credits has evolved into a multibillion dollar business.
So banking might not be up your straight,
but the bank's role of providing funds to people and businesses is crucial for
our society and has to be done.
Who will do it and how it will be done in the future is up for us to design
though.